foreign
[Music]
my name is glennis loxton and I'm a
postdoctoral research fellow in Evan
eichler's laboratory at the University
of Washington
today I'm super excited to tell you
about my work to determine the first
complete telomere to telomere sequence
of a human autosomal chromosome and that
chromosome 8.
I'll tell you how we use the combination
of Longview sequencing Technologies to
determine the structure of this
chromosome where every base is resolved
from end to end
I'll also highlight some biological and
phylogenetic analyzes that we performed
to determine the function and evolution
of the chromosome 8th Century over the
last 25 million years
we are in a very exciting time in
genomics because we are in an era where
telomere to telomere chromosome
assemblies are becoming a reality
and this has been a long time coming if
you look at an early draft of the human
genome in 2001 you can see just how
fragmented it was it had over a thousand
gaps and complete absence of centromeres
segmental duplications and acrocentric
regions
but we've come pretty far in the last 20
years and because of advances in Long
read sequencing and computational
assembly tools we are now beginning to
close these gaps
now our human genome looks like this
this is the latest draft of the human
genome assembled by the telomerated
telomere Consortium and you can see that
it's much improved
only five gaps remain and these are
located in the acrocentric P Arms but
importantly we have telomere to telomere
Assemblies of 18 whole chromosomes
while it would be lovely to think that
you know we went from the fragmented
2001 genome to the 2021 genome very
easily the truth is is that it was a
very challenging project that took
several years
and in fact we assembled each chromosome
kind of in a stepwise manner
the first chromosome we tackled was
chromosome X which we published in
nature 2020 and once we had success with
our sex chromosome we said hey let's go
after an autosome and so our next
chromosome we assembled was chromosome 8
which was published only a couple weeks
ago in nature and that's what I'm going
to tell you about today
so chromosome 8 actually had five
challenging regions to resolve the first
are the telomeres which were found at
the Caps or the ends of the p and the Q
arm of this chromosome
additionally we had the beta defense and
segmental duplication which is a
whopping seven megabase pairs long and
it's one of the most structurally
dynamic regions in the entire human
genome
additionally we had the centromere which
is around 2 megabase pairs long and
comprised of near identical tandemly
repeated Alpha satellite sequences
and finally we had the aq21 variable
number tandem repeat which is around 900
kilobase pairs long
for the purpose of this presentation I'm
going to highlight the centromere which
is one of the more complicated regions
to resolve in the chromosome
so I'll tell you a little bit about the
centromere how we resolved it and what
we discovered both biologically and
evolutionarily in this region
so to give you a bit of a background the
centromere is a special Locus that's
found on each of our chromosomes and it
has a very unique organization
in a typical centromere it has an array
of what is known as higher order repeats
which can span somewhere between 2 and 5
megabases On Any Given chromosome
these higher order repeats are organized
in a head-to-tell fashion but
occasionally there will be some unique
structural variants like this inversion
I'm showing here as well as this variant
which is just a high order repeat of a
different size
the reason that centrumors have been so
challenging to resolve over the past 20
years is because they're so identical
for example these two higher order
repeats I'm showing here are typically
97 to 100 identical to each other
additionally higher order repeats are
themselves composed of alpha satellite
repeats
so the reason that centromeres are so
difficult to resolve is because they're
technically a repeat of repeats and
they're so large and highly identical
so how do we resolve the centromere well
we use laundry sequencing
to demonstrate why long wreaths are so
important for traversing complex repeat
regions like the centromere I figured I
would show you an example that can that
compares alumina short resequencing with
two leaders in the long resequencing
Fields pack bio Hi-Fi and ont
so if you're an Illumina short read
you're probably somewhere between 75 to
250 base pairs long but you're really
really accurate you're over 99.9
accurate
with a short Illumina Reed we can place
this Reed here but because it's so short
it doesn't capture this complex genomic
variation that we would need in order to
span a centromere so the same read could
be placed here and in fact it could be
placed in nine different locations
within the centromeric array
if you're a pack bio High fibroid you're
probably something like 15 to 25
kilobase pairs long and you're over 99
accurate
I like to think of pacbile HiFi reads as
being really long Illumina reads because
they are long they're like 15 to 25 KB
but they're over 99 accurate which is
approaching that alumina level accuracy
with the pack about HiFi read this
accurate you actually can place it
within the centromeric array and the
reason you can do that is because it
contains something known as a singly
unique nucleotide Kamer or sunk
a sunk is a sequence of length K that's
found only once in the genome so you can
place this read in this location on the
Central America array because it
contains the sunk that's only found in
that exact location in the array
however there will be times when a 55
read is not long enough to capture a
sunk so it will be you know it will be
unclear where it's supposed to be placed
if you're an Oxford Nano Ford technology
read or an ont read you're typically
somewhere between 10 and over a thousand
KB long but you're only 93. to 99
accurate
if you have an ont read that's hundreds
of KB long you can definitely place it
within the centromeric array and the
reason you can do that is because it
captures this unique conversion and
variant that allows it to Anchor
precisely to that location in the array
so we think that PayPal Hi-Fi and ont
data actually have complementary
strengths Pacquiao Hi-Fi is a long read
that has that over 99 accuracy while ont
is a super ultra long read and while
it's less accurate it has that length
that is able to Traverse these complex
repeat regions
so we decided that we should combine
pac-bow Hi-Fi and ont reads in an
assembly pipeline that takes advantage
of their complementary strengths
so we developed a strategy to resolve
complex repeat regions in the human
genome and it goes like this
first we generate Ultra long ont reads
these are reads that are over 100 KB in
length and so I'm showing you a read
links distribution here where the reads
are about averaging about 140k being
long
additionally we generate pack bio Hi-Fi
reads these are reads are only 15 KB
long but once again they have that
really high accuracy that's 99.9 or
greater
we then barcode Ultra long ont reads
with sunks to remind you sunks are those
single unique nucleotide cameras which
are only found Once In The genome
so these sunks when you put them on the
o and t reach they generate something
that looks like this which is a unique
barcode or a unique pattern that's
specific to that region of the genome
you can take ont reads that have these
unique patterns and then line them up
with each other overlapping where they
have that shared barcode and then you
can generate it into a scaffold
so here I'm showing you oneont based
scaffold where we combine Ultra long ont
reads to generate the sequence that
traverses the complex repeat region
but like I mentioned before ont reads
aren't the most accurate in fact they're
only 90 to 90 93 to 99 percent accurate
so to improve the accuracy of this
assembly we actually replace ont
scaffold with the pack bile HiFi context
that we assembled from the Paco HiFi
data this brings the accuracy of this
region up to over 99.9 which is aluminum
level accuracy
we then take this Hi-Fi based assembly
and integrate it into a whole chromosome
assembly that we have that chromosome
generating a complete telomated telomere
sequence that's over 99.9 percent
accurate
so we applied this method to the
chromosome 8 centromere and it was
absolutely successful so here I'm
showing you the first linear sequence of
a human autosomal chromosome centromere
and as you can see it's comprised of
2.08 megabase pairs of alpha satellite
higher order repeats which are flanked
on either side by monomeric Alpha
satellite that is interspersed with
lines ltrs and signs on the P arm
organic satellite lines ltrs and signs
on the q line
whenever we assemble a centromere we
always get the question how do you know
it's accurate so we actually perform a
complementary Suite of experiments that
combines both
wet lab and dry lab experiments to show
that this is actually correctly
assembled
so first the first thing we do is align
pack file Hi-Fi reads to the assembly
and what we want to see is this very
even coverage across the entire array
which we do see here for both Paco HiFi
and ont
if there was a misassembly you would
expect to see a collapse or a spike in
coverage but because we don't see that
we believe this is very um
this validates our assembly at least to
some extent
the second way we used we validated this
assembly was to use a restriction digest
followed by a pulse Hill gel and
Southern block so we selected two
restriction enzymes that cut rarely
within the higher order repeat array but
would generate unique enough size
fragments that we could separate on a
pulse filled gel
when we ran this on a gel and then used
a chromosome 8 specific Alpha satellite
probe to pick it up we found that it
absolutely recapitulated our prediction
and it gave the expected band pattern
that you would see if the assembly was
correct
so once we had this assembly we asked
ourselves what does the epigenetic map
of the centromere look like
so we took assembly and aligned Ultra
long ont reads to it and then called uh
detected methylated cytosines or
unmethylated cytosines using nanopolish
so here I'm showing you methylated
cytosines in red and unmethylated signs
in blue and the thing that stood out to
us was that the centromere actually
harbored the 673 kale base pair dip in
methylation
we immediately thought to ourselves
perhaps this is the location of the
epigenetic centromere or the the site of
the kinetochore so in order to test this
we performed sempei chip seek on the
chromosome on the entire chm13 genome
and then mapped the Reeds to the
location and we found that the sympae
actually is encompasses the 73 KB dip
and spans about 632 kilobase pairs of
sequins
because of this we think this is the
likely site of the kinetochore and it's
the first time this has ever been shown
that you can actually identify the site
on linear sequence in the centromere
after we determined the epigenetic
landscape of this instrument we asked
ourselves
how has the centromere evolved over time
to answer this question we took this
sequence assembly and we fragmented it
into five kilobase per segments aligned
all the segments to each other to
generate pairwise sequence alignments
and then plotted the sequence identity
of each pair along the centromere this
gave us a sequence identity heat map
which is shown here
so this shows the pairwise sequence
identity by a 5k by square fragments
from the entire centromere and their
color coded so that the lower sequence
identity is around 75 percent and and is
dark purple and the high sequence
identity around 100 percent is dark red
so there were a couple things that
immediately stood out to us about this
centromere assembly the first is the
mere symmetry of it you can see that on
the edges of the centromere we have
Divergent sequences that are low
sequence identity only 75 percent
interestingly these two regions only
have similarity with each other and not
with any of the other sequence within
the core
this led us to our other idea that we
found is that there's a layered nature
of the centromere
we were able to identify five major
layers in the centromere the first is
this most ancient layer coming from the
Divergent sequences on the periphery of
the centromere and you can also see a
second smaller layer where these two
regions flanking the higher order repeat
array have some sequence similarity and
then third is this layer which is the
more identical region it's the
transition between the monomeric alpha
satellite and the higher order repeat
array
this mirror symmetry and layered nature
of the centromere reminds us of a model
that was first proposed by smithdol in
where young young repeats are born
within the center of the centromere and
they push older more Divergent repeats
to the edges to create this kind of
mirrored layered nature where young
repeats are in the center and more
ancient and diverse ones around the
periphery
this was very very exciting to us and at
and it kind of inspired us to look more
into the evolution of the chromosome 8
centromere so to do this we actually
um looked back into their primate
Evolution where we had chimpanzee
gorilla orangutan Gibbon Emma CAC and we
sequenced and assembled the chimpanzee
orangutan and macaque genomes with
Pacquiao HiFi and ont Technologies and
then tried to assemble their centromeres
so as you know we already assembled the
human centrumer we were able to get both
chromosome 8 centromeres from the
chimpanzee this is the first diploid
primate Century assembly ever
we were also able to get an orangutan
chromosome a centromere and I'm a cat
chromosome 8 centimeter so in the next
few slides I'm going to show you what
these censioners look like and then how
we use these sensual mirrors to
determine how this instrument has
evolved over time
so the first one I want to highlight is
the chimpanzee centromere this one is
actually very similar in size to the
human one it's um 1.4 megabase pairs as
compared to the human which was 2.08
but once again it's very striking we see
a mirror symmetry with Divergent
sequences on the edges and this layered
nature where higher sequence identity
Alpha satellite repeats are found in the
core and become more Divergent as you
head out towards the periphery
this is the first centromere haplotide
but of course we assembled
sorry these are the layers the second
centromere as well
and once again we see this Divergent
Alpha satellite on the edges that create
this mere symmetry with the layered
nature found in each of the edges as we
progress towards the core of this
engineer
the orangutan sentiment was actually
very striking
and while it did have that mirror
symmetry with the Virgin Alpha satellite
on the edges and that layered nature
that we had seen before we saw something
that we hadn't seen in the human in the
chimpanzee which is that we see two
distinct higher order repeat sections
that are fighting for dominance we think
that these two regions probably evolved
at the same time and are kind of
competing to see who will take over one
another
based on sequence identity which is dark
red
Evan and I think that this um this
smaller one is actually more recently
evolved and is probably going to take
over the more Divergent one here in the
orange
finally we generated the macaques and
schmear I want to point out that the
macaque centromere is 10.93 megabase
pairs long which is incredibly big
compared to the 2.08 that we had in the
human version
strikingly this one is comprised of not
off satellite higher order repeats but
just dimers this is the ancient
fundamental repeat unit that we probably
all evolved from
once again despite this we had the mere
Symmetry and layered nature that we
found in all the other primate
centromeres
so in order to reconstruct The
evolutionary history of the chromosome
8th Century we took all of the alpha
satellite monomers that exist in all of
those primate centromeres and then build
to file a genetic tree which I'm showing
you here
what we see is that there are five major
clades that the alpha satellite monomers
cluster in and I want to go through them
with you right now
so first is this great ape higher order
Alpha satellite clade here I'm showing
in blue where all of these Alpha
satellite monomers are coming from and
all of them are clustering together we
also have the great ape mon America
Alpha satellite which is on the edges of
that centromere and you can see that
they also cluster together
the macaque Alpha satellite clusters in
two evolutionarily distinct claves
although they are both dimeric and
monomeric we see that one is actually
closer to the grade eight while the
other one is at least 25 million years
away from the rest of the grade eight
Alpha style lives
and finally and perhaps most
interestingly we see a subset of human
chimpanzee monomeric Alpha satellite
that's clustering closer to the macaque
dynamerican monomeric at the bottom of
this tree we think that these repeats
shown in red are likely uh the vestigial
centromere that's left over from the
great
um great ape Alderwood Mac display
so we were also able to calculate a
mutation rate for this engineer and we
did this by taking 10 KB fragments and
creating a multiple sequence alignment
across all the members of the hominid
hologram
we can see that as we progress from the
unique sequence on the p and the Q arm
the Divergence from chm13 increases for
chimpanzee orangutan and macaque
this occurs within the monomeric alpha
satellite even before we hit the higher
order repeat array
we actually were able to detect that
this has an increased mutation rate
which is at least 2.2 to 3.8 fold higher
than the rest of the human genome
we want to note that we think that this
is a minimum because we were unable to
actually calculate the rate within the
higher order repeat array just because
they're so incredibly Divergent that we
couldn't get multiple sequence elements
so it's likely that the true centromeric
mutation rate is somewhere between 5 and
10 folds higher than the rest of the
genome
so with all this combined we were able
to establish a model of superstitioner
evolution we think that human Alpha
satellite higher order repeats are born
in the core of the centromere and they
push the older ones to the edges to form
this unique marriage Symmetry and
layered nature that we observe in all of
the human primate and non-human primate
um
centimeter assemblies
so together I was able to show you that
we developed a new targeted assembly
method that leverages the strength of
ont and pack bio Hi-Fi sequencing to
resolve complex regions and primate
genomes
I also showed that we could apply this
method to resolve the centromere in a
diploid genome and that's the chimpanzee
one
and finally I showed that an
evolutionary model to explain the
mirrored and layered nature of the
centromere which Builds on the
hypotheses first proposed by George
Smith and Valerie shopalev
as far as next steps we're planning to
chart the evolution of other primary
centramers by sequencing and assembling
them in other species and assessing
their organization and evolution
to give you a taste of the the work
that's currently ongoing I want to show
you the evolution of a complex layered
centromere
so this is the stenchmere from
chromosome 17 and it's more complex in
chromosome 8 because it contains three
Alpha satellite high order repeat arrays
shown here at the top
despite the fact that there's three
there's still this mirrored and layered
nature that we can see
however we do want to point out that
there's this Alpha satellite higher
order repeat on the left that is
substantially different from the rest of
the center
we were able to assemble the chromosome
17th century in chimpanzee as well and
here's what it looks like there although
it's very similar in size it once again
recapitulates the mirrored nature and
layered symmetry that we have seen
before in the other centromeres with
this particular one shown in the circle
as being preserved from the human
finally I wanted to show you the
orangutan centromere which is even
bigger when you take into account all
the other higher order repeat arrays but
once again we see this more Divergent
layer that's occurring on the left side
of the centromere that we think has been
diverging ever since the split from
great apes the great ape split
so with that I'd like to acknowledge all
the people who contributed to this um to
this effort first and foremost is the
Ico lab the main players are of course
of an Eichler and Mitchell vulture a
graduate student who's been helping me
with the computational assembly pipeline
who are super important for the
phylogenetic analyzes that were carried
out and of course I'd like to thank
members of the telomere to telomere
Consortium which is led by Adam
Philippine Karen Miga these people were
absolutely essential in validating the
assembly that we had put forth in making
sure all of it was correct
thank you so much for your time and I
look forward to receiving your questions